This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。百分之百真人。快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。但现在，有一种全新且令人兴奋的方法，可以开启你通往更快乐生活之旅。快乐 101。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotb）主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感，以最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播访谈。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。
Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. My first guest is Paris Hilton, Shakira, Luke and Yerrin. You have surprises? Many surprises. Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast where the group check comes to life. What on? You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst.
搜索“快乐 101”并立即收听。由 CVS 呈献的、由霍达·科特比主持的《快乐 101》。我的第一位嘉宾是帕丽斯·希尔顿、夏奇拉、卢克和耶林。你有惊喜？很多惊喜。欢迎来到 Sweet 305 播客，群聊在这里变为现实。怎么了？你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。
It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons on the IHard. radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born.
是柠檬味的。这里是 Sweet 305。在这里，过度分享受到鼓励。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听由莱勒·庞斯（Lele Pons）主持的 Sweet 305。每个人都把我当作一名足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍然在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存，自打我出生以来。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tchariot-Ornandez, and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. I'm Munga Chitigler and I'm back with a new season of my podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I talked to scientists, biopunks, kermudgens, blues owners, super seniors, and Goa's top cryotherapy lab to try to understand this obsession with living forever
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的，只是一些关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·查蒂奥特-奥尔南德斯（Javier Chicharito-Hernández），在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习成为人类》（Learning to Be Human）。我是曼加·奇蒂格勒（Munga Chitigler），我带着我的播客《天际大道》（Skyline Drive）的新一季回来了。这一次，我与科学家、生物朋克、脾气暴躁的老头、蓝调音乐老板、超级老年人和果阿顶尖的冷冻疗法实验室进行了交谈，试图理解这种对长生不老的痴迷，
and what it means for all of us. And I get into a bit of trouble along the way. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. Make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
以及它对我们所有人意味着什么。这一路上我也惹上了一些小麻烦。我会说大概从“骨骼重塑”开始。那不管用。让它看起来更有线条感。他们说管用。我不知道。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 上收听《天际大道：如何长生不老》（Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever），
or wherever you get your podcast. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rappaport Stereo podcast, is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention,
或在你获取播客的任何地方。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特（Michael Rappaport），我的播客《我是拉帕波特立体声播客》（The I Am Rappaport Stereo Podcast）与你听过的任何播客都不同。如果你正在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何其他吸引我注意力的事物的强烈观点，
then subscribe now. This kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson. Listen to I Am Rappaport on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast. Just a reminder, before we get into this topic, you can now watch full video episodes of the podcast,
那就马上订阅吧。这个叫贾法尔·杰克逊（Jafar Jackson）的小伙子绝对应该因他对迈克尔·杰克逊的塑造而被提名。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 上收听《我是拉帕波特》。或在你获取播客的任何地方。只是提醒一下，在我们进入这个话题之前，你现在可以观看播客的完整视频单集，
including this episode right here on Netflix. Link will be in the description. Hello, everybody. I'm Jemis Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody.
包括就在 Netflix 上的这一集。链接将在简介中。大家好，我是杰米·斯派克（Jamies Spike），欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s, our 20s, my 20s, all of our 20s. This is maybe the most important episode I'm going to make this whole year because unlike some of my episodes which, you know, might not have. apply to everyone. I think this one definitely does in a way that is honestly a little bit scary to acknowledge. We're talking about the loss of our attention spans and our attention just in
欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能来到这里收听又一集节目，当然，我们在这里剖析你二十多岁的心理、我们的二十多岁、我的二十多岁、我们所有人的二十多岁。这可能是今年我制作的最重要的一集，因为不像我的一些节目那样，你知道的，可能并不适用于所有人。我认为这一集绝对适用，而且其程度老实说有点让人感到害怕去承认。我们在讨论注意力的丧失以及我们的注意力，
general, possibly the most precious resource we have as humans. Where is it disappearing to? And how are we going to get it back? I would say the majority of us feel that our attention spans are noticeably nothing like they used to be. Not to speak for everyone, obviously, but I don't know, I can recall a time when I could read books for hours with ease in a way that feels almost unfathomable today. I could sit and focus on a singular task, like studying, and stay on that task for more than five minutes, that's for sure,
总的来说，这可能是我们人类拥有的最宝贵的资源。它正在消失到哪里去了？我们要如何把它找回来？我想说，我们大多数人都觉得，我们的注意力明显大不如前了。当然，不是说所有人，但我不知道，我能回忆起曾经我可以毫不费力地连续几个小时读书，这种感觉在今天几乎是不可思议的。我可以坐下来专注于一项单一的任务，比如学习，并且绝对可以专注于该任务超过五分钟，
more than 45 minutes, more than an hour at times, with like very relative ease. Nowadays, it can feel like, it feels like our brains are these tiny frogs jumping from lily pad to lily pad, unable to stay on one for longer than a few minutes, always needing two or three or four activities going on at once to feel entertained and to feel satisfied.
超过四十五分钟，有时甚至超过一个小时，而且相对来说非常轻松。如今，这种感觉可能会让人觉得，我们的大脑就像是一只只小青蛙，在荷叶之间跳来跳去，无法在任何一张荷叶上停留超过几分钟，总是需要同时进行两项、三项或四项活动才能感到娱乐和满足。
I used to think it was because I just wasn't disciplined enough or I was lacking the structure of being in high school or university, but now I don't think so. Something else has also almost fundamentally changed about our society that we need to look into. Now this is not just anecdotal. This isn't just me. This isn't just you. There's real data and research to back up this experience. One of the best indicators of this is a long research project undertaken at the University of California. It was started 20 years ago. this research involved this woman, Professor Gloria Marks and her team, following a group of people around for days at a time, carrying stopwatches to time how long people spent on tasks before switching, before doing something else. When they started this research in 2004, this is the year they found the average attention span was around two and a half minutes.
我曾经以为这是因为我自己的纪律不够好，或者我缺乏高中或大学时那种结构化的约束，但现在我不这么认为。我们的社会也发生了某种几乎是根本性的变化，我们需要深入探讨这一点。现在，这不仅仅是轶事。这不仅仅是我。这不仅仅是你。有真实的数据和研究来支持这种体验。这方面最好的指标之一是加州大学（University of California）进行的一项长期研究。这项研究始于 20岁年前。这项研究涉及这位女性格洛里亚·马克思教授（Professor Gloria Marks）和她的团队，他们连续几天跟踪一群人，手里拿着秒表计时，记录人们在切换任务、做其他事情之前在任务上花多长时间。当他们在 2004 年开始这项研究时，这是他们发现平均注意力跨度约为两分半钟的一年。
That was their baseline. They did the study again, eight years later in 2012. They started using more precise computer logging techniques. They found that the average attention span is sitting in a little bit more than like around a minute, around 75 seconds. The most recent data from Mark's team actually only came a few years ago. And they found the average attention span going from, has gone from two and a half minutes to 47 seconds. in the past 20 years, that is the rate at which we are increasingly finding ourselves distracted, switching from task to task. Our attentional capacity has rapidly decreased. So what we need to ask is
那是他们的基线。八年后的 2012 年，他们再次进行了这项研究。他们开始使用更精确的计算机记录技术。他们发现平均注意力跨度稍微缩短了一点，大约是一分钟左右，大约 75 秒。马克思团队最近的数据实际上是几年前才得出的。他们发现平均注意力跨度从过去的两年半缩短到了 47 秒。在过去的 20 年里，这就是我们发现自己越来越容易分心、在任务之间不断切换的速度。我们的注意力容量正在迅速下降。所以我们需要问的是，
basically what's going on. What's going on culturally? What's going on psychologically? What's going on neurologically that has allowed this to happen? And what are the actual practical things that we can do to fix it because I don't know about you. I'm kind of bored of the same basic. Stop scrolling, go outside advice. There has to be more to it. So I went and found it. And I'm going to give you guys the real tangible scientific tips to regain your attention span all in this one big comprehensive episode. Without further ado, let's get into it. So let's start with this. Why have our attention spans become so afraid and so difficult to control. Firstly, we need to take a look at our brains, specifically the role of dopamine, to kind of understand what reprogramming has been at play.
基本上发生了什么。文化上发生了什么？心理上发生了什么？神经学上发生了什么，导致了这种情况的发生？我们到底能采取哪些切实可行的措施来解决它，因为我不知道你们怎么样。我已经有点厌倦了那些老生常谈的“停止刷手机，去户外”的建议了。这背后一定还有更多原因。所以我去找到了答案。我将在这一个巨大、全面的节目中，为您提供真实、切实的科学建议，以恢复您的注意力跨度。闲话少说，让我们切入正题。那么，我们从这里开始。为什么我们的注意力变得如此脆弱、如此难以控制？首先，我们需要审视我们的大脑，特别是多巴胺的作用，以便理解究竟是哪种重编程在起作用。
So if you listen to our history and psychology of dopamine episode a couple of weeks ago, you'll know this well, you'll know this very well, but dopamine isn't the pleasure chemical. Many of us think that it is. It's the anticipation chemical. When we look at, neuroimaging studies that map the release and flow of dopamine and the activity of dopamine producing centers in the brain, what we find is that our dopamine levels rise as we anticipate a reward, anticipate a payout, I should say, anticipate something happening. They spike whilst we wait for that thing and whilst we wait to obtain it and they kind of decrease once we get it. Dopamine is deeply tied to something psychologists call reward prediction,
因此，如果你听了我们几周前关于多巴胺的历史和心理学的那集节目，你就会对此非常了解，你会非常清楚这一点，但多巴胺并不是快乐化学物质。我们很多人都以为它是。它是期待化学物质。当我们查看神经影像学研究，那些绘制多巴胺释放和流动以及大脑中多巴胺产生中心活动的地图时，我们发现，当我们期待奖励、期待回报（我应该这么说）、期待某事发生时，我们的多巴胺水平就会上升。在我们等待那件事发生以及等待获得它的过程中，它们会飙升，而一旦我们得到了它，它们就会有所下降。多巴胺与心理学家称之为奖励预测的东西有着深厚的联系。
Essentially, our brain is constantly scanning the environment, asking what's going to be interesting here, what's going to be pleasurable, what's going to be useful or emotionally stimulating, and how can we move further towards those things? How can I get closer to those things? It is what drives that motivation and that movement by getting us excited for what comes next. It's not just pleasure, it's anticipation. Evolutionarily, you know, dopamine was incredible. incredibly powerful as many of us needed to migrate in search of food and migrate in
本质上，我们的大脑一直在扫描周围环境，询问这里有什么会是有趣的、愉快的、有用的或能刺激情绪的，以及我们如何才能朝着这些事情进一步移动？我怎样才能离这些事情更近一点？正是这种东西通过让我们对接下来发生的事情感到兴奋，来驱动这种动机和运动。这不仅仅是快乐，更是期待。从进化论的角度来看，你知道的，多巴胺是不可思议的，
such of shelter. We needed to be patient. We needed to stick to hard things to get stuff done. We needed to wait for the harvest, wait until danger had passed, whatever. Dopamine is what allowed us to do that by imagining the pleasure or microdosing us with the pleasure of finally getting a meal, finally getting a safe place to lay down, finally getting whatever it was that we had to work for. The problem is in this day and age, we don't really have to wait that long for anything anymore. We don't have to wait for food. We have Uberites. We have grocery stores. We have ready-made meals. We don't have to take time or put an effort to entertain ourselves. We don't have to wait that long for information. You know, we can Google it. We can use AI if you want to go
极其强大，因为我们许多人需要迁徙去寻找食物，迁徙去寻找栖息地。我们需要保持耐心。我们需要坚持做困难的事情来把事情做好。我们需要等待收获，等待危险过去，无论是什么。多巴胺正是通过想象快乐，或者用最终吃上一顿饭、最终找到一个安全的地方躺下、最终获得我们不得不为之努力的任何东西的快乐给我们进行微量给药，从而使我们能够做到这一点。问题是，在当今时代，我们真的再也不需要为任何事情等待那么久了。我们不需要等待食物。我们有 UberEats。我们有杂货店。我们有现成的饭菜。我们不需要花时间和精力来娱乐自己。我们不需要为获取信息等待那么久。你知道的，我们可以用谷歌搜索。如果你想更上一层楼，还可以使用人工智能。我们不需要为社交反馈或社交信息等待那么久，
that extra level. We don't have to wait that long for social feedback or social information. either or the pleasure of being around people. It's served up to us in this nice, bite-sized device or dose on social media. There's no longer a need for patients and for sustained anticipation. Where does that leave our dopamine systems that have adapted for a completely different scenario? What this does for us psychologically is it begins to train the brain to expect constant novelty and rapid emotional, psychological and physical payoff. The brain is highly adaptive. It learns from repetition. So when we repeatedly move towards quick rewards, our attentional system starts calibrating itself around speed, immediacy and stimulation rather
无论是哪一种，也无需等待与人相处的快乐。这一切都以精致、一口大小的设备或社交媒体上的剂量呈现在我们面前。不再需要耐心和持续的期待。这让我们为完全不同的场景适应了的多巴胺系统情何以堪？从心理学上讲，这为我们带来的影响是，它开始训练大脑去期待不断的尝鲜和快速的情绪、心理以及身体回报。大脑具有高度适应性。它从重复中学习。因此，当我们重复朝着快速奖励移动时，我们的注意力系统就开始围绕速度、即时性和刺激性进行自我校准，而不是
than patience and slowness. When we're constantly anticipating and immediately getting, anticipating and immediately receiving, our brains are naturally being flooded with more and more dopamine because those hits are coming faster. This reduces our brain, sense, so that when we do have to do tasks that require fixed, sustained attention, the normal release of dopamine that is at an appropriate level that previously would have sustained you just doesn't cut it anymore. We are used to getting hit after hit after hit. Tasks that unfold slowly. Reading a difficult book. Sitting down and actually planning and writing an essay. Sitting with your thoughts, studying, even watching a full movie without checking
耐心和缓慢。当我们不断地期待并立即获得、期待并立即接收时，我们的大脑自然会被越来越多、越来越多的多巴胺淹没，因为这些多巴胺带来的冲击来得更快。这降低了我们大脑的感知能力，以至于当我们确实必须去做那些需要固定、持续注意力的任务时，处于适当水平、以前可以维持你注意力的正常多巴胺释放根本就不管用了。我们习惯了一次又一次、接二连三的刺激。那些缓慢展开的任务。阅读一本困难的书。坐下来真正规划并撰写一篇论文。静静地思考、学习，甚至不看手机地看完一整部电影，
your phone, they begin to feel disproportionately effortful because they cannot compete with the pace of this modern day dopamine delivery system. What we really have here is a dopamine sensitivity issue, not a dopamine level issue. That's another common myth. There's also another important concept here, which is called delay discounting. This was first mentioned in a book by the economist, Irving Fisher back in the, I don't even know, way back when it's since found a very important place in psychology and it's the idea that humans naturally value immediate rewards more highly than delayed ones. Basically, you'd probably rather I give you $30 now than the promise of maybe getting $50 in six months. This obviously used to be important for survival. Don't expend energy
它们开始让人觉得付出不相称的努力，因为它们无法与现代多巴胺输送系统的速度相竞争。我们这里真正面对的是多巴胺敏感度问题，而不是多巴胺水平问题。这是另一个常见的神话。这里还有另一个重要的概念，叫做延迟贴现。经济学家欧文·费舍尔（Irving Fisher）在一本书中首次提到了这一点，甚至不知道是在什么遥远的过去，自那以后它在心理学中找到了一个非常重要的位置，这个观点就是人类天然地比延迟的奖励更高度地重视即时的奖励。基本上，你可能宁愿我现在给你 30 美元，也不愿承诺六个月后可能会给你 50 美元。这显然过去对生存很重要。不要把精力浪费在承诺上。
on a promise. You know, take what you can now if you need to live. A bird in the hand is better than two in the bush, like all those kind of things. But modern life has amplified this tendency enormously to the point where it's no longer useful. It's actually disruptive. You know, why spend two hours learning a skill when you can get a tiny hit of achievement instantly from clearing emails or buying something online or refreshing your messages or ticking off a small, easy task? Our brains start prioritizing rewards that are fast and frictionless over rewards that are meaningful and slow. Here's something to know. A 2012 study published in the journal Psychology and Neuroscience found that people who have high rates of delay discounting, basically people who are more willing
你知道，如果你需要活下去，现在能拿多少就拿多少。双鸟在林不如一鸟在手，诸如此类。但现代生活极大程度地放大了这种倾向，以至于它不再有用了。它实际上具有破坏性。你知道的，为什么要花两个小时去学习一项技能，当你可以通过清理电子邮件、在网上买东西、刷新消息或勾选一个小型、简单的任务来瞬间获得微小的成就感呢？我们的那些快速且无摩擦的奖励，开始被我们的大脑优先于那些有意义但缓慢的奖励。这里有一点需要了解。发表在《心理学与神经科学》（Psychology and Neuroscience）杂志上的一项 2012 年的研究发现，那些延迟贴现率高的人，也就是那些更愿意
to forego smaller immediate rewards and wait or work for something larger, not only have stronger attentional control, which is basically what we're talking about today, but are more likely to be successful, may be wealthier, may have and be in better health. But this is becoming it harder and harder because, again, of the technological and physical environments that we find ourselves in. In particular, we really just can't have this conversation without talking about social media. And the fact that social media has literally been designed with knowledge of how our attention systems work and therefore the ability to hijack it using anticipation reward cycles, not to sound too conspiratorial. But to generate ad revenue, social media companies need to make sure that we are
放弃较小的即时奖励并等待或为更大目标而努力的人，不仅拥有更强的注意力控制力（这基本上就是我们今天讨论的内容），而且更有可能成功、可能更富有、可能拥有更好的健康状况。但这变得越来越困难，因为再次说明，由于我们所处的科技和物理环境。特别是，我们真的不能不谈论社交媒体就开始这个对话。事实上，社交媒体的设计正是基于对我们的注意力系统如何运作的了解，因此它有能力利用期待-奖励循环来劫持注意力，听起来虽然有点像阴谋论。为了产生广告收入，社交媒体公司需要确保我们
scrolling for as long as possible. Every element of the user interface, please make no mistake, every single social media platform you use. The certain features are chosen because they work to attract and capture people's attention. Things that you may not even be aware of are doing this. For example, the infinite scroll, the fact that you never get to the bottom of whatever you're scrolling, the frictionless nature of scrolling. Have you ever noticed with Instagram, TikTok, everything there's literally no clicking or movement of the finger required. The physical movement of watching is very smooth. You just move your finger ever so slightly, right in the middle of the spring. So there's very little reason for you to step away.
尽可能长时间地刷手机。用户界面的每一个元素，请不要误解，你使用的每一个社交媒体平台。某些功能之所以被选择，是因为它们能够吸引和捕捉人们的注意力。你甚至可能没有意识到它们正在这样做。例如，无限滚动，你永远无法滚动到你正在浏览的内容的底部这一事实，滚动的无摩擦性。你有没有注意到在 Instagram、TikTok 上，所有内容实际上都不需要点击或移动手指。观看的身体动作非常流畅。你只需在屏幕正中央稍微动一下手指即可。所以你几乎没有任何理由离开。
There's even the fact that the algorithm, your algorithm, is designed specifically for you. That is all those are all design features that were chosen to get you addicted. There was a really great paper on this called Digital Slot Machines, Social Media Platforms as Attentional Scaffolds from 2004 where they also talk about how the recent push of really emotionally salient and at times emotionally triggering content also plays a role in pushing emotional reinforcement videos of people crying, celebrity drama content, that kind of stuff. It pushes that emotional reinforcement and therefore lessens attentional control. If we boil it down, really, to its baseline, you could say social media platforms may seem free to use, but they're not. You are the product. Your attention
甚至还有一个事实，即算法、你的算法是专门为你设计的。所有这些都是为了让你上瘾而选择的设计特征。2004 年有一篇非常棒的关于这方面的论文，名为《数字老虎机：作为注意力支架的社交媒体平台》（Digital Slot Machines, Social Media Platforms as Attentional Scaffolds），其中他们还讨论了最近对真正具有情感显著性有时甚至是情感触发的内容的推动，如何在推动情感强化方面发挥作用——哭泣的人的视频、名人八卦内容，诸如此类。它推动了这种情感强化，从而减弱了注意力控制。如果我们把社交媒体真正归结到其基线，你可以说社交媒体平台看起来是免费使用的，但事实并非如此。你就是产品。你的注意力
is the product. And because of that, it is something that people want possession over. In the words of Barber Dramericks, I think her name is, she's a famous book. professor, if you use social media, there is no way that you can have a normal brain today. And yet we are being told to blame ourselves for our dwindling attention spans as if it is a motivational or disciplinary issue, which is ironic because discipline is an individual issue. But it appears if we take this perspective to be declining on a mass scale. So there's obviously a bigger factor going on here. This is not just a you problem.
就是产品。正因为如此，它是人们想要占有的东西。用芭芭拉·德拉梅里克斯（Barber Dramericks，我大概念对她的名字了）的话来说，她是一位著名的图书教授，如果你使用社交媒体，你今天绝对不可能拥有一个正常的大脑。然而，我们却被告知要为我们不断萎缩的注意力怪罪自己，就好像这是一个动力或纪律问题一样，这很讽刺，因为纪律是一个人的问题。但如果我们认为这种观点正在大规模下降，那似乎就不是了。所以这里显然存在一个更大的因素。这不仅仅是你个人的问题。
This is not that every single person has lost discipline. something else is going on. One more point on this because I found this really interesting as well. The very way not just social media has been designed, but the internet in general has been designed is also incredibly neurologically significant for our attention. Professor Gloria Mark, she is the one who did that research originally. She has been a key figure in research on attention and the impact of technology upon it for almost 20 years. Like she is like the goat of this. She argues that the very design of not just social media, but the internet maps very well onto somatic memory theory. The idea that memory is organized in terms of making associations between concepts.
这并不是说每个人都失去了纪律。有什么别的事情正在发生。关于这一点还有最后一点，因为我也觉得这非常有趣。不仅是社交媒体的设计方式，整个互联网的设计方式对我们的注意力来说也具有极其重要的神经学意义。格洛里亚·马克思教授，就是最初进行那项研究的人。近 20 年来，她一直是研究注意力及其受技术影响的关键人物。就像她就像这个领域的山羊（GOAT）。她认为，不仅是社交媒体，互联网的设计本身就与语义记忆理论高度吻合。记忆是通过在概念之间建立联系来组织的这一观点。
Our brains love this. The internet with its kind of node and link structure, so like, you know, enter here, then it diverts you to somewhere else, is conducive to distraction because information is organized in terms of associations. A Wikipedia page is the perfect design. You read a topic, you see a link, you click on that link, you find another link. Suddenly you've read like a million articles. If you read an article online, you've recommended three others that are similar. If you get shown a certain video and you like it, suddenly four more just like it will show up on your feed. That is literally how memory works.
我们的大脑喜欢这样。互联网具有节点和链接的结构，比如，你知道，在这里输入，然后它把你引向别处，这很容易导致分心，因为信息是根据关联来组织的。维基百科页面就是完美的设计。你阅读一个主题，你看到一个链接，你点击那个链接，你发现另一个链接。突然之间，你已经阅读了大约数百万篇文章。如果你在线阅读一篇文章，系统会向你推荐另外三篇类似的文章。如果你看到某个视频并且你喜欢它，突然之间又有四个与之类似的视频会出现在你的动态中。这字面意思就是记忆的工作原理。
You know, you have a memory, suddenly you're thinking about something else and then you're thinking about something else. It's all very deliberate. Let's do a quick rapid run through of some other factors that have disturbed our attention spans that don't have to do with social media. There's just some things that we're also seeing decline. People are getting less sleep. You know, I think as you get older, you care more about your eight hours. At least that's how I've found I'm maturing.
你知道的，你有一个记忆，突然你在想别的事情，然后你在想别的事情。这一切都是非常深思熟虑的。让我们快速浏览一下其他一些扰乱我们注意力跨度、与社交媒体无关的因素。还有一些我们同样看到在下降的事情。人们的睡眠越来越少。你知道的，我想随着你年龄的增长，你更在乎你的八小时睡眠。至少这就是我发现自己成熟的方式。
But when you don't get enough sleep, you accumulate sleep debt. Greater the sleep debt, greater your attentional and cognitive decline. And people are sleeping a lot less, actually. A study from 2017 showed how much. not, like how significant not getting enough sleep is for our attention, what they found was that they basically subjected these guys, these men, to sleep deprivation and then asked them to do a bunch of tasks. Performance on all the tasks showed substantial deterioration when they were sleep deprived, but particularly tasks that have to do with attention and mental functioning. It might sound
但当你睡眠不足时，你就会累积睡眠债。睡眠债越大，你的注意力和认知下降就越大。事实上，人们的睡眠少了很多。2017 年的一项研究显示了多少。不是，睡眠不足对我们的注意力有多大影响，他们发现基本上是将这些家伙，这些男性，置于睡眠剥夺状态，然后要求他们做一堆任务。当他们睡眠不足时，所有任务的表现都出现显着恶化，特别是与注意力和心理功能有关的任务。这听起来可能
extreme. Like they've, they did deprive them of sleep for a long time. But even like another study from 2019 that had people sleep for just six hours a night for 10 consecutive days also found a similar decrease in attention as if you were not to sleep for 48 hours. Sleep deprivation also intensifies and destabilizes our emotional responses in our amygdala. That's what drives our response to stress. So we feel more reactive. We feel more anxious. We feel more on edge. Our attention also reduces because of that. Like stress, lack of sleep, social media, all combining to put pressure on our attention, but also combining and included in that is like stress about the world, stress about your job, stress about friends. It's also meaning that the appeal of
很极端。就像他们确实剥夺了他们很长时间的睡眠一样。但就像 2019 年的另一项研究让人们连续 10 天每晚只睡六小时一样，也发现了类似注意力的下降，就像你连续 48 小时不睡觉一样。睡眠剥夺还会加剧并破坏我们杏仁核中的情绪反应。那是驱动我们对压力反应的东西。所以我们感觉反应更强烈。我们感觉更焦虑。我们感觉更紧张。正因为如此，我们的注意力也会下降。就像压力、睡眠不足、社交媒体，所有这些结合起来对我们的注意力施加压力，但其中也结合并包括了对世界的压力、对工作的压力、对朋友的压力。这也意味着
social media and things like that and the appeal of fast-dove mean is greater because it's so instantaneous. We're so stressed by everything else in our lives. We don't want to work to be entertained. We don't want to work to find out information. We don't want to work for anything. And finally, we are experiencing greater levels of physical disruption and distraction than ever before. More people are moving to cities. More people are living in urban areas. By 2050, UN thinks 70% of the world's population is going to live in a city developed or urban space. What that means is more exposure to noise, light pollution, distraction, other people, busy public transport, crowded spaces.
社交媒体之类的事物以及快多巴胺的吸引力变得更大，因为它是如此即时。我们对生活中所有其他事情都感到压力重重。我们不想为了娱乐而努力。我们不想为了寻找信息而努力。我们不想为任何事情努力。最后，我们正在经历比以往任何时候都更高程度的物理混乱和分心。越来越多的人搬到城市。更多的人生活在城市地区。到 2050 年，联合国认为世界上 70% 的人口将生活在城市发达或城市空间中。这意味着更多地暴露在噪音、光污染、分心、其他人、繁忙的公共交通、拥挤的空间中。
Do not overestimate what that does to you on a daily basis. The sensory and social overload of that means we always need to be on. If we don't feel on, our brain at least needs to be on, even if we want to clock out for a bit. And we do have limits. We do have limits. And when we hit them, when our brain hits them, our minds and our attention, our minds and our attention suffers. In 2011, scientists found that two regions in our brain involved in the regulation of emotion and anxiety and attention become overactive in city dwellers. You know, you don't always
不要高估这每天对你做的事情。这种感官和社会超载意味着我们需要始终处于开启状态。如果我们感觉没有开启，我们的大脑至少需要开启，即使我们想暂时下班休息一下。我们确实有限制。我们确实有限制。当我们的达到限制时，当我们的大脑达到限制时，我们的思想和注意力，我们的思想和注意力就会受损。2011 年，科学家发现，我们大脑中参与调节情绪、焦虑和注意力的两个区域在城市居民中变得过度活跃。你知道，你并不总是
think it has an impact until you leave. I just went to like a cabin the other day and this like isolated cabin outside of London. And within 24 hours, it felt like someone had put a sedative in the air. Like, I played Scrabble for three hours straight. I felt my attention. intentional systems regenerate, being out of a city, being out of a high stress, high stimulation environment. So that's basically what's contributing. There's a couple of the things. I think those are the biggest ones. We are going to take a short break here. And when we return, we're going to talk about the signs that you may need an attentional reset and seven science-backed ways to do it. So stay with us.
认为它有影响，直到你离开。我前几天刚去了一个小木屋，伦敦郊外的一个孤立的小木屋。在 24 小时内，感觉就像有人在空气中投放了镇静剂。就像，我连续玩了三个小时的拼字游戏。我感觉到我的注意力。注意力系统再生了，摆脱了城市，摆脱了高压力、高刺激的环境。所以这基本上就是导致这种情况的原因。还有其他一些事情。我认为这些是最大的。我们在这里稍作休息。当我们回来时，我们将讨论可能需要重置注意力的迹象以及做到这一点的七种有科学依据的方法。所以请继续关注我们。
An IHART Radio experience, weekend gold tickets to Ilsoniq. One, two, three. With Dom Dalla, Chris Lakin friends, Woolly, Deadmouse, above and beyond, subfocus, and more. With flights from Porter Airlines, three nights at Residence Inn downtown Montreal, and $1,000 cash. Enter for your chance to win at iHeartRadio.ca. Ilsonique in Montreal, every day you enter is another chance to win. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbby. Okay, if you know me, you know this.
iHeartRadio 体验，Ilsoniq 的周末黄金门票。一，二，三。与 Dom Dolla、Chris Lake and friends、Wooli、Deadmau5、Above & Beyond、Sub Focus 等等。包含 Porter Airlines 的机票、蒙特利尔市中心 Residence Inn 的三晚住宿以及 1,000 美元现金。在 iHeartRadio.ca 输入以获取您的中奖机会。蒙特利尔的 Ilsonique，您输入的每一天都是另一个中奖机会。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《霍达·科特比的快乐 101》的主持人。好的，如果你了解我，你就会知道这一点。
I'm always searching for inspiration, for support, and useful tools to help maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover all of that together. We're going to have these meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges that she never saw coming. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Olympic champ Sean Johnson revealed why she had no choice but to be a gymnast. There was something about gymnastics that was intoxicating to me. It's given me a belief that we all
我一直在寻找灵感、支持和有用的工具，以帮助最大化快乐。所以这个播客让我们一起揭开这一切的面纱。我们将与世界上最迷人的人进行这些有意义的对话，比如当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服她从未料到的严峻健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更加困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。奥运冠军肖恩·约翰逊（Sean Johnson）透露了她为什么别无选择只能成为一名体操运动员。体操有些东西对我有种陶醉感。它给了我一种信念，即我们所有人都
have one of those treasures inside of us. We just have to find it. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your My first guest is Paris Hilton, Shakira, Luke and Yerrin, Samira, and Gracie. I'm so excited on the bouncy bed. You have surprises? Many surprises. Welcome to Sweet 305 where the group chat comes to life. What a f***.
内心深处藏着那些宝藏之一。我们只需要找到它。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听由霍达·科特比主持的《快乐 101》。我的第一位嘉宾是帕丽斯·希尔顿、夏奇拉、卢克和耶林、萨米拉和格雷西。我在蹦床上感到非常兴奋。你有惊喜？很多惊喜。欢迎来到 Sweet 305，群聊在这里变为现实。真特么的。
It's like a way to say like, Oh, my name, hello, my friend, oh, my brother. What a . Look, I've never ever had to have to be a nobody. Except with my kids, my kids, and my kids, You know. C. My Amant.
这就像是一种表达方式，比如，哦，我的名字，你好，我的朋友，哦，我的兄弟。什么。听着，我从来没有不得不成为一个无名小卒。除了和我的孩子们，我的孩子们，我的孩子们，你知道的。看。我的爱人。
Oof. That's incredible. Yeah. The telenovela. You're the only person I know that loves a Yellow Starburst. It's laminated. No, there's someone. Like, you'd like to collaborate with this person.
呜。太不可思议了。是的。肥皂剧。你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。是压扁的。不，有人。就像，你愿意和这个人合作。
This is Sweet 305. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons as part of my Cultura Podcast Network on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. Everyone is a total of excitement because their new star is Javier Tchirito Hernandez is from Mexico Everyone sees me as a football player But before anything else, I'm human Every single day I'm still learning
这里是 Sweet 305。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方，收听作为我的 Cultura 播客网络一部分的由莱勒·庞斯主持的 Sweet 305。每个人都充满了兴奋，因为他们的超级新星是来自墨西哥的哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当作一名足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍然在学习
How to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born And I still have so many questions Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love?
如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存，自打我出生以来。我依然有这么多的疑问。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你怎么处理被取消？C 罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？
Real Madrid or Varsa? From every day and ordinary to the deal? deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table,
皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常和普通到深入和非凡？这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱性在这里显现，
and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has a perfect and all is just. Wait me, I'm going to pressur me, but me will go to be going to connect. The Chicharito. And Javier and Chicharito Hernandez, and together with Iha Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close.
阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和教训被分享。生命中的这一切都是完美且公正的。等等我，我要压力我，但我要去连接。这位是奇查里托。和哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯一起，与 iHeartRadio 一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。
It is a crack. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHad Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Munga shit together and I'm back with a new season of the podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I'm diving into a rabbit hole of peptides, organoids, blood boys, blue zones and brain replacement to try to understand what this longevity obsession is all about and what it really means to live forever for all of us. I learned about some rad science. I can make a brain.
这是一个绝佳的绝招。哇。在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习成为人类》。我是曼加·奇蒂格勒，我带着播客《天际大道》的新一季回来了。这一次，我深入研究了肽、类器官、年轻血液、蓝色地带和大脑替换的无底洞，试图理解这种对长寿的痴迷究竟是怎么回事，以及对我们所有人来说，永远活着到底意味着什么。我学到了一些很酷的科学。我可以为你制造一个大脑，
for you, and then we can test what draw is the best for your brain, as opposed to his brain. Here's some hard truths. I would expect Indians to age faster, but I did not expect it to be almost a four to five-year acceleration. And get myself into a world of trouble. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. Make it look more defined.
然后我们可以测试哪种药物最适合你的大脑，而不是他的大脑。这里有一些残酷的真相。我本以为印度人衰老得更快，但我没想到会加速近四到五年。并且让自己陷入了各种麻烦中。我会说大概从“骨骼重塑”开始。那不管用。让它看起来更有线条感。
They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the Island. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So if you're still doubting whether your attention is really that affected by social media, by your environment, by your sleep, by whatever it is, here are five smaller signs that you can check yourself against really quickly to tell you, do I have a problem or not? Number one, do you frequently use more than one screen at a time? So you're on your phone and you're watching TV. You're on your laptop, maybe at the same
他们说管用。我不知道。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《天际大道：如何长生不老》。所以如果你还在怀疑你的注意力是否真的受到了社交媒体、你的环境、你的睡眠或任何其他因素的影响，这里有五个较小的迹象，你可以非常快地对照检查一下自己，以告诉你：我到底有没有问题？第一，你是否经常同时使用多块屏幕？所以你一边看手机一边看电视。也许你同时还在用笔记本电脑。
time. Number two, do you struggle with boredom and silence? How often do you need to have music on the background or a YouTube video playing? How often do you feel like you need to watch something up until the moment that you put your head on the pillow or you need to open social media first thing in the morning? Number three, do you pick up hobbies, activities, projects regularly and abandon them just as fast when they require more effort and time than you think. Number four, after you finish a meal, how long do you sit at the table thinking, just enjoying yourself? Or do you feel like you need to rush off? Do you feel like you need to leave the restaurant as soon as you're done eating? You need to go somewhere else. You always need to be in transit to somewhere else,
第二，你是否在面对无聊和沉默时感到挣扎？你多久需要在背景中播放音乐或 YouTube 视频？你多久会觉得，在把头枕到枕头上的那一刻之前，你都需要看点什么，或者你需要在早晨醒来的第一件事就是打开社交媒体？第三，你是否经常开始培养新的爱好、活动、项目，而当它们需要比你想象的更多的精力和时间时，又同样快速地放弃它们？第四，吃完饭后，你会在桌旁坐多久思考，纯粹享受自己？还是你会觉得自己需要匆忙离开？你会觉得只要一吃完饭就得离开餐厅吗？你需要去别的地方。你总是需要去往别处的途中，
even if you're not busy. Number five, what speed do you watch things on? What speed do you listen to things on? Do you watch everything at one and a half speed when you watch really? You watch really, when you listen to podcasts. Do you watch videos or TikToks you see all the way through? Or do you just keep scrolling and only wait for the first five seconds? Bonus number six. Do you struggle to pay attention to long stories from people? Or do you struggle to have sustained conversations,
即使你并不忙。第五，你以什么速度观看内容？你以什么速度收听内容？你在看 Reels 时，所有东西都开 1.5 倍速看吗？你在听播客时。你看视频或 TikTok 时会从头看到尾吗？还是你会一直向下刷，只等前五秒？附加第六条。你是否很难集中注意力听别人讲长故事？或者你是否很难维持长期的对话，
often finding yourself kind of zoning in, wanting the person to move on, speed up, go on to the next thing? Now, if you have ADHD, maybe you relate to these because you have ADHD. And some of the things we mention as tips might not help you in the same way because, you know, your attention is being impacted by different neurological and biological reasons. It's not just environmental. We've done a full episode recently on the psychology of ADHD with an expert, Chris Wang, end of last year, that goes into that a lot further.
经常发现自己有点放空，希望对方赶紧说完、快进、进入下一件事？现在，如果你有 ADHD（注意力缺陷多动障碍），也许你能对这些产生共鸣，因为你有 ADHD。我们作为小贴士提到的一些事情可能无法以同样的方式帮助你，因为，你知道，你的注意力正受到不同的神经和生物学原因的影响。这不仅仅是环境问题。我们最近邀请了一位专家克里斯·王（Chris Wang）制作了一集关于 ADHD 心理学的完整节目，年底的那期对此进行了更深入的探讨。
But I do still think some of these tips we're going to talk about are useful. With that being said, I think if you have ADHD, it's a different can of fish. some of this advice isn't going to work for you. I still think it's important to listen anyways. But if you don't have ADHD, if you're just noticing kind of a normal fluctuation in your attention, I think to start, if you are on this mission to win back your own attention and to be able to find that delayed gratification high, firstly, you've got to know what's motivating you to want this without a clear vision for why you want to get your attention back, why you want to achieve this mental feat, it's going to be hard to follow through.
但我仍然认为我们将要讨论的一些小贴士是有用的。话虽如此，我认为如果你有 ADHD，那是完全不同的一回事。其中一些建议对你不起作用。我依然认为无论如何听一听是很重要的。但如果你没有 ADHD，如果你只是注意到注意力有正常的波动，我认为首先，如果你正在执行赢回自己注意力的任务，并能够找到延迟满足的高潮，首先，你必须知道是什么在激励你想要这个。如果没有一个清晰的愿景说明你为什么想要找回注意力，为什么想要实现这一心理壮举，你将很难坚持到底。
So after you've finished listening to this podcast, I want you to grab a pen and a piece of paper and kind of write a master list by hand, if possible, that you keep somewhere important that details, why do I want to fix my intentions, Ben? What is my motivation behind, wanting to spend less time on social media, wanting to be more present? Here's some inspiration for things that can be on that list. perhaps you want to spend more time actually noticing the world around you. Maybe you want to make active decisions about how you spend your time without feeling like
所以在你听完这个播客后，我希望你拿出一支笔和一张纸，如果可能的话手写一份总清单，把它保存在某个重要的地方，上面详细说明：我为什么要修复我的注意力跨度？我想花更少的时间在社交媒体上、想要更专注于当下，背后的动机是什么？这里有一些可以列入该清单的事情的灵感。也许你想花更多时间真正注意你周围的世界。也许你想对你如何度过时间做出主动决定，而不觉得
that decision is always being hijacked or you're always being controlled by whatever gives you the quickest spike of dopamine. Maybe there are lots of other fun things that you want to do with your life. You claim not to have time, but you want to see if that's actually true. Perhaps you want to get your attention span back because you want to experience, you know, the high of consistency and slowly achieving things. Maybe you want more alone time. Maybe you want to be able to really focus on certain goals. Maybe you want to get more things on your to-do list done. Maybe you just realize, like, I want to just be present with people. When I'm with people, I want to be able to
这个决定总是被劫持，或者你总是被任何能给你带来最快多巴胺飙升的事物所控制。也许你的生活中还有很多其他你想做的有趣事情。你声称没有时间，但你想看看这是否属实。也许你想找回你的注意力跨度，因为你想体验，你知道的，持续性的高潮和慢慢取得成就的快感。也许你需要更多独处时间。也许你想能够真正专注于某些目标。也许你想在待办事项清单上完成更多事情。也许你只是意识到，我想和人们在一起时专注于他们。当我与人们在一起时，我希望能够
listen to their long, sometimes boring stories because I love them. I want to feel less anxious about what's going on elsewhere. I want to be capable of doing difficult things because I think for the first time in history, maybe life is easier than it's ever been. And I don't want that to just constantly be my reality. I think that is a great place to start. Why do you want to achieve this goal? There's so much research, including a recent study from the Dominican University of California that shows writing down a goal, writing down your intentions, increases your chances of success by 42%. So that's the first thing. Now for the more practical stuff, I also want you start by knowing your attentional baseline. This was a strategy put forth by Daniel Pink. He's the
听他们讲那些漫长、有时甚至有些无聊的故事，因为我爱他们。我想对外界发生的事情少一点焦虑。我想具备做困难事情的能力，因为我觉得，或许有史以来第一次，生活比以往任何时候都要轻松。而我不希望这种状态一直成为我的全部现实。我认为这是一个很好的起点。你为什么要实现这个目标？有大量的研究，包括加利福尼亚多明尼加大学最近的一项研究表明，写下目标、写下你的意图，能将你的成功几率提高42%。所以这是第一点。现在谈谈更实用的一些事情，我还希望你从了解自己的注意力基线开始。这是丹尼尔·平克提出的一项策略。他是
author of the book, Whole New Mind, the surprising truth about motivation, the power of regret. He speaks about how when he noticed his attention span was getting worse, he decided essentially if I want to improve, I need to know what I'm starting with. I need to know, I need to have some kind of measurement that I can track my improvement from. His way, of measuring his attentional baseline was that he sat down with the book and he timed how long he could actually sit and read and concentrate on reading before he found like he had to get up, before he felt uncomfortable, before he felt like he just needed to get a glass of water, needed to skip forward a few pages. He then started trying different exercises for attentional control and he would come back
畅销书《全新思维：全脑时代的优势》、《动机的惊人真相》以及《悔恨的力量》的作者。他谈到，当他发现自己的注意力持续时间越来越糟时，他基本上决定，如果我想进步，我需要知道自己的起点是什么。我需要知道，我需要某种衡量标准，以此来追踪我的改进。他衡量注意力基线的方法是，他坐下来看一本书，并计时记录自己实际上能坐多久、阅读并专注于阅读，直到他觉得不得不站起来、直到他感到不舒服、直到他觉得只是需要去喝杯水、需要往后跳读几页。然后，他开始尝试不同的注意力控制练习，并且会隔几个月、几年，
to this book and come back to this exercise again, a few months, a few years and just see if he was improving, see what was helping. You need this. You need a version of this. Any researcher will tell you if you want to see if an intervention is working, such as an intervention to get your attention back, you've got to know what the situation was like to begin with to see if it's made a change. So try it this week. Sit down with a book or an article or any activity that requires sustained attention. How long can you stay in that space? That is your baseline. Couple months later, test it again. Okay, these next points are the intervention that we're speaking about.
再回到这本书和这个练习中来，看看自己是否有在进步，看看是什么在起作用。你需要这个。你需要这个版本的练习。任何研究人员都会告诉你，如果你想看看某种干预措施是否有效，比如找回注意力的干预措施，你必须先了解最初的情况是怎样的，才能看出它是否带来了改变。所以这周就试试吧。坐下来读一本书、一篇文章，或者进行任何需要持续注意力的活动。你能在这个状态下坚持多久？这就是你的基线。几个月后再测试一次。好了，接下来的这些要点就是我们要讨论的干预措施。
Number one, you don't have to stop using your phone. You don't have to stop using screens right away. But if you want to get your attention back, single screen always. Here's the thing. We like to believe that we are really good multitaskers. And we're really not. There was a University of Utah paper, now very famous one actually, by David Sabomatsu, I think his name was, he found that only 2% of the population can actually
第一点，你不需要停止使用手机。你不需要立刻停止使用屏幕。但如果你想找回注意力，始终只用一个屏幕。事情是这样的。我们喜欢相信自己非常擅长多任务处理。而事实并非如此。犹他大学曾发表过一篇论文，现在其实非常有名，作者好像叫大卫·萨博松（David Sabomatsu），他发现只有2%的人口能够真正的
multitask, and that's being very generous. Here's another surprising thing he found in that research. The people who are most capable of multitasking, that rare 2% are probably not the people you're going to find actually doing it. Most of us should not be doing this. Oftentimes when we're doing work with a TV show on in the background, even listening to a podcast, even scrolling while watching a lecture, we're not actually multitasking in a way that's actually productive. We're sensation-seeking. That sensation-seeking causes us to attention switch much quicker than usual, and that depletes our attentional capacity and exhausts us much faster. One statistic even says that task or attentional shifting, so going from your phone to the lecture
多任务处理，而且这已经是很宽泛的说法了。他在那项研究中发现的另一个惊人之处是，最具备多任务处理能力的人，那稀有的2%，很可能不是你真正会发现正在这样做的人。我们大多数人都不应该这样做。通常，当我们一边放着电视剧背景音一边工作，甚至听着播客，甚至在看讲座时刷手机，我们并不是在以真正高效的方式进行多任务处理。我们是在寻求感官刺激。这种寻求感官刺激的行为会导致我们比平时更快地进行注意力切换，这会消耗我们的注意力容量，让我们更快地精疲力竭。甚至有一项统计数据表明，任务或注意力的切换，也就是从手机切换到讲座
to the computer, costs us as much as 40% of our daily productive time without us realizing it. basically when you switch when you are or when you're trying to do multiple things at once and thinking you can pay attention to shopping for something on your phone whilst trying to put together a plan on your laptop for a class whilst emailing you think that you can do those all at once and you're not going to notice a difference your brain still needs to catch up so one screen at a time even better if you schedule your switches so basically you know that you have to do 40 minutes of deep work on your laptop, and then you'll get 10 minutes just of pure phone time, maybe even 15. You know, you have to sit at your laptop for those designated 40 minutes. Even if you're not getting anything done,
再到电脑，会不知不觉地夺走我们高达40%的日常高效时间。基本上，当你切换时，当你正在或试图同时做多件事情，以为自己可以一边在手机上挑选商品，一边试图在笔记本电脑上为课程制定计划，同时还发着邮件，你认为你可以同时做好这些并且不会发现有什么区别，但你的大脑仍然需要时间来跟上节奏。所以一次只用一个屏幕，如果你能规划好切换时间就更好了，基本上，你知道你需要在笔记本电脑上进行40分钟的深度工作，然后你会有10分钟甚至15分钟纯粹的手机时间。你知道，在那指定的40分钟里，你必须坐在笔记本电脑前。即使你什么都没做，
you're still strengthening your attentional band, then you get the reward. You still get time for these things, but they're segmented. I think after a short period of procrastination, you'll definitely be surprised by how quickly you are able to get into a deep flow state knowing that your time is reserved just for this one activity or this one screen. And getting into a state of deep flow is going to become, I think, increasingly valuable in this attention economy. There's this guy's named Cal Newport. He's the author of Deep Work.
你仍然在强化你的注意力区间，然后你就能得到奖励。你依然有时间做这些事情，但它们是被分割开来的。我想经过短暂的拖延之后，你肯定会惊讶于，当你知道自己的时间只保留给这一个活动或这一个屏幕时，你是多么快就能进入深度心流状态。而且，进入深度心流状态在当今这个注意力经济中，我认为会变得越来越有价值。有一个人名叫卡尔·纽波特。他是《深度工作》的作者。
And he wrote about this recently that he basically said, as like AI takes over, as social media becomes more prominent, the people who are going to rise to the top, the people who are going to be successful are those who could sit down and can still sit down and commit to a task that requires sustained attention. You can have a master's degree. You can have a bachelor's degree. You can have heaps of experience. Whatever skill you have, Excel, Google, I don't know what skills people put on their resumes these days,
他最近写到了这一点，他基本上说，随着人工智能接管一切，随着社交媒体变得越来越突出，那些能够脱颖而出、那些能够获得成功的人，将是那些能够坐下来、并且依然能够坐下来致力于完成一件需要持续注意力任务的人。你可以拥有硕士学位。你可以拥有学士学位。你可以拥有丰富的经验。无论你有什么技能，Excel、谷歌，我不知道现在人们简历上都写什么技能，
but like whatever skill it is, the one people are going to want the most is the person who can sit down and just focus and just work. That is what you are building by not always splitting your attention between multiple tasks and multiple screens. Other ways, I think, to form a healthier relationship with your phone. Don't just put up social media blocks or timers because they're not going to work and it's going to feel like you're doing something when you're not. They're so easy to skip. Instead, treat your phone like a landline. When you get home, immediately plug it in, and it stays in that one location at all times. You can use it for whatever you want.
但不管是什么技能，人们最想要的将是那个能够坐下来专心致志工作的人。这就是你通过不总是将注意力分散在多个任务和多个屏幕之间所要构建的东西。我认为，与手机建立更健康关系的其他方法。不要只是设置社交媒体拦截器或定时器，因为它们不管用，而且会让你觉得自己在做事其实并没有。它们太容易跳过了。相反，把你的手机当成固定电话来对待。当你回到家时，立刻把它插上充电，并且它始终待在那一个地方。你可以用它做任何你想做的事。
You can use it as much as you like. You can scroll for as many hours as you desire. You have to be where the phone is. It helps if that location is obviously not next to your bed or next to your couch, but somewhere a little bit inconvenient where you need to stand, for example, maybe in your kitchen. But it helps you have a better relationship with being able to turn away. from it. You can also turn your phone screen to grayscale, only use social media on your laptop,
你可以随心所欲地使用它。你想刷几个小时都可以。你必须待在手机在的地方。如果这个地方显然不在你的床边或沙发旁边，而是在某个稍微有点不方便、需要你站起来的地方，比如可能在你的厨房里，那就更有帮助了。但这有助于你与它保持距离，建立更好的关系。你还可以把手机屏幕调成灰度，只在笔记本电脑上使用社交媒体，
delete your most stimulating like apps over the weekend. There's so many creative ways that don't require complete abstinence, but they create, I don't know, can I say intuitive usage, almost like intuitive eating? That's the way I see it. It's intuitive usage. Second piece of advice, every single day, if you want to get your attention span back, give yourself an attention broadening exercise where you just focus on one thing for 30 minutes. This doesn't have to be screen free, but it does have to be scrolling or task switching free. Deep concentration on one thing is a great, great way to train your brain to pay attention and rebuild the ability for your attention to sit within itself for longer. Some examples you can commit to reading an in-depth
在周末删除你最容易兴奋的那些应用。有那么多富有创造性的方法，不需要完全戒断，但它们创造了——我不知道，我可以说直觉式使用吗？就像直觉式饮食那样？我是这样看的。这就是直觉式使用。第二个建议，每一天，如果你想找回注意力，给自己安排一个注意力拓宽练习，让你专注于一件事30分钟。这不一定非得无屏幕，但必须是没有刷手机或任务切换的。对一件事进行深度集中，是训练大脑集中注意力、重建注意力长时间停留能力的极佳、极佳的方法。一些例子包括，你可以致力于阅读一篇深入的
op-ed for half an hour. That was my task today. I just read a New York Times article about who gets custody over IVF embryos. That's what I did. I just sat there for 30 minutes and I read every word start to end even when I wanted to skip certain bits or jump ahead. Like I had to read it word for word. I know that sounds like a brag that I read an article. I don't know. I don't mean it to be, it was actually kind of hard, but that's what I've been getting myself. to do. The sense of satisfaction afterwards as well, I just told you guys about it. Obviously, I feel good that I did it and I feel good every day that I do it. Other examples for your daily 30 minutes sustained attention practice cook a meal without listening to a podcast at the same time
专栏文章半小时。这就是我今天的任务。我刚刚读了一篇关于谁来获得体外受精（IVF）胚胎抚养权的《纽约时报》文章。这就是我做的。我只是坐在那里30分钟，从头到尾读了每一个字，即使我想跳过某些部分或向前跳读时也是如此。我必须逐字逐句地阅读。我知道这听起来像是在吹嘘我读了一篇文章。我不知道。我不是这个意思，这其实挺难的，但这就是我一直让自己在做的事情。事后的满足感也是如此，我刚刚才跟你们讲过。显然，我为自己做到了这一点感觉很好，而且我每天这样做都感觉很好。日常30分钟持续注意力练习的其他例子还有：做一顿饭，同时不听播客
or music or anything. Do a crossword or do Sudoku for 30 minutes, just you and the Sudoku book without picking up your phone, without, again, listening to things. Walk to the shops without having your AirPods in 30 minutes, 30 minute walk, just you and nature. Sit and just listen to a podcast and take notes without doing anything else. The singularity is important. Adam Brown, he is the co-director of the Center for Attention, Learning and Memory at New York University. He says that gently nudging ourselves in the direction of long-term focus on things
或音乐或任何东西。做30分钟的填字游戏或数独，只有你和数独书，不拿起手机，同样不听任何东西。走路去商店，不戴AirPods，30分钟，30分钟的步行，只有你和大自然。坐下来，只是听一听播客并做笔记，不去做任何其他事情。单一性很重要。亚当·布朗，他是纽约大学注意力、学习与记忆中心联席主任。他说，温和地引导自己朝着对事物长期专注的方向发展，
works as a form of mental muscle memory. This is your attention, gym, you're going to every day. The same way you do 30 minutes, 45 minutes, an hour of exercise a couple times a week, or probably every day, like you're doing this for your brain. You are building cognitive endurance, which is your ability to sustain mental activity over a continuous stretch of time. There was a study published just last year, actually, in an economics journal, no less, and it randomly assigned 1,600 school children to 20-minute increments of sustained
其作用就像是一种心理肌肉记忆。这是你的注意力健身房，你每天都要去。就像你一周去几次，或者可能每天都进行30分钟、45分钟、一小时的锻炼一样，你在为自己的大脑做这件事。你正在建立认知耐力，也就是你在连续一段时间内维持心理活动的能力。去年其实刚刚发表了一项研究，而且还是在经济学杂志上，它随机分配了1600名学龄儿童，每天进行20分钟的持续
attentional focus a day. Some of them got it, some of them didn't. The children who participated in this exercise once a day saw that cognitive endurance and performance increase by 22% compared to those who didn't do that. I'm basically asking you to do this experiment on yourself, 20 to 30 minutes a day, the same way you exercise, shower, eat, have your attentional exercises as well. I'll also slip in this other tip in here as well, because I think it kind of relates to the strategy somewhat, but if you want an easy boost to attention, stop walking or running with your headphones in, see how long that you can endure silence. I know this. It feels like listening to music as we move through the world isn't harming us at all. It's not really doing anything. It seems harmless,
注意力集中练习。其中一些儿童进行了，另一些没有。参与这项练习的儿童，其认知耐力和表现比没有这样做的儿童提高了22%。我基本上是要求你在自己身上做这个实验，一天20到30分钟，就像你锻炼、洗澡、吃饭一样，也进行你的注意力练习。我还要顺便分享另一个小贴士，因为我觉得它在某种程度上与这个策略有关，但如果你想轻松提升注意力，就不要戴着耳机走路或跑步，看看你能忍受多久的沉默。我知道这一点。感觉我们在世间穿梭时听着音乐似乎对我们没有任何害处。它其实没做什么。这似乎无害，
right, but there's actually a growing body of research suggesting that constantly pairing movement with audio stimulation. So music, podcast videos, voice notes may increase what psychologists call cognitive load, meaning the total amount of mental effort your brain is using at one time. Even if it is harmless, your brain is still processing language, predicting sound patterns, filtering information and dividing your attentional resources between your environment and the audio stream. One relevant concept here is something called attentional residue, which was coined by Dr. Sophie Leroy in a 2009 study she did on, once again, on multitasking. And this is the idea that when part of our attention is allocated to one stream of information, some of it will always stick there,
对吧，但实际上越来越多的研究表明，不断将运动与音频刺激结合在一起——也就是音乐、播客视频、语音备忘录，可能会增加心理学家所说的认知负荷，这意味着你的大脑在任何特定时间使用的心理努力总量。即使它是无害的，你的大脑仍在处理语言、预测声音模式、过滤信息，并在你的环境和音频流之间分配你的注意力资源。这里一个相关的概念叫做“注意力残留”，这个词是由索菲·勒鲁瓦（Sophie Leroy）博士在2009年的一项研究中提出的，该研究再次关注的是多任务处理。这个概念的意思是，当我们的一部分注意力分配给一个信息流时，其中一部分总会停留在那里，
even as we try to focus elsewhere. So if you're walking or studying or working whilst listening to a podcast, listening to music, trying to do anything, if you have this in the background, mentally your brain is always partially occupied by it, no matter how much you've listened to that song, even if there's no words, your brain never fully enters a state of open awareness or even of rest, just like when you have two screens. this is obviously kind of a bummer because music also is shown to reduce stress, also shown to
甚至在我们试图专注于其他地方时也是如此。因此，如果你在听播客、听音乐、试图做任何事情的同时走路、学习或工作，如果你背景里放着这些，从精神上讲，你的大脑总是会被它部分占据，无论你听过这首歌多少遍，即使没有歌词，你的大脑也从未真正完全进入开放意识甚至休息的状态，就像你有两个屏幕时一样。这显然有点令人沮丧，因为音乐也被证明可以减轻压力，还被证明可以
increase life satisfaction and the emotional salience of memories and moments and it's just joyful, like you don't need a scientific reason to justify that music is beautiful. But again, I'm not saying, you know, from now on, it's silence for you and you only. Like, music is not something you can enjoy until you fix that like pesky attention span of yours. I'm just saying be more aware of what taxes your attention span in the background that you may imagine as harmless but is actually just normalized. Okay, we're going to take our final break for this episode before we finish off. Good job if you have made it this far without taking any other breaks without skipping forward. Your attention span is doing well today. Stay with us. We're going to return
增加生活满意度以及记忆和时刻的情感显著性，而且它纯粹是快乐的，就像你不需要一个科学理由来证明音乐是美好的。但同样，我不是说，你知道，从现在开始，对你来说只有绝对的沉默。就像，音乐并不是在你修复了那个讨厌的注意力持续时间之前无法享受的东西。我只是说，要更加意识到背景中那些你可能觉得无害、但实际上已经被日常化的、对你的注意力持续时间造成负担的东西。好了，在我们结束之前，我们要进行本集的最后一次休息。如果你在没有进行任何其他休息、没有快进的情况下坚持到了这里，做得很好。你今天的注意力持续时间表现不错。跟我们在一起。我们马上回来
for those final tips and some finishing thoughts. Close your eyes. And you can hear the entire world come alive. 2026 FIFA World Cup is on. And you can stream it all live on TSN Radio. From the opening kickoff to the final celebration, every match, every moment. Listen to FIFA World Cup on TSN Radio. Gives Canada to the Lift Off!
带来最后的那些小贴士和一些结束语。闭上眼睛。你能听到整个世界苏醒过来。2026年国际足联世界杯开赛了。你可以在TSN电台上直播收看所有的比赛。从开球到最后的庆祝，每一场比赛，每一个时刻。在TSN电台上收听世界杯。将加拿大带向起飞！
Available on IHeart Radio. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbby. Okay, if you know me, you know this. I'm always searching for inspiration, for support, and useful tools to help maximize joy. So this podcast lets us uncover all of that together. We're going to have these meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges that she never saw coming.
可在IHeart Radio上收看。嘿，我是霍达·科特布（Hoda Kotb），播客《与霍达·科特布共度欢乐101》（Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb）的主持人。好的，如果你了解我，你就知道这一点。我一直在寻找灵感、支持和有用的工具，以帮助将快乐最大化。所以这个节目让我们一起探索所有这一切。我们将与世界上最迷人的人进行这些有意义的对话。就像当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服她从未料到的严峻健康挑战时。
I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer. and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartum depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Olympic champ Sean Johnson revealed why she had no choice but to be a gymnast. There was something about gymnastics that was intoxicating to me. It's given me a belief that we all have one of those treasures inside of us. We just have to find it.
我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，而那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。奥运冠军肖恩·约翰逊（Sean Johnson）透露了她为什么别无选择、只能成为一名体操运动员。体操对我有种让人着迷的东西。它让我相信，我们每个人的内心深处都藏着那样一件宝藏。我们只需要找到它。
Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Paris Hilton, Shakira, Luke and Yerrin, Samira and Gracie. I'm so excited on the bouncy bed. You have surprises, many surprises. Welcome to Sweet 305 where the group chat comes to life. What a fuck. It's like a way of saying like, hello, my friend, hello, my brother. What a!
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《与霍达·科特布共度欢乐101》。我的第一位嘉宾是帕丽斯·希尔顿（Paris Hilton）、夏奇拉（Shakira）、卢克（Luke）和叶林（Yerrin）、萨米拉（Samira）和格雷西（Gracie）。我在弹簧床上超级兴奋。你们有惊喜，很多惊喜。欢迎来到《Sweet 305》，群聊在这里变为现实。天哪。这就像是一种表达方式，比如，你好，我的朋友，你好，我的兄弟。哇！
Look, never I've ever been talking to anyone. Except with my kids, my kids, my children, and my children, if you know. I'm sorry. Oof, that's incredible, yeah, the telenovela. You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. And no, there's someone. I'd like to collaborate with this person.
听着，我从来没有和任何人聊过天。除了我的孩子们，我的孩子们，我的孩子们，如果你们懂的话。我很抱歉。呜，太不可思议了，对，那部电视剧。你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。不，还有一个人。我想和这个人合作。
This is Sweet 305. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons as part of my Culture Podcast Network on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. Their new star is Javier Tichorito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born.
这里是《Sweet 305》。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，收听由莱勒·庞斯（Lele Pons）主持的《Sweet 305》，作为我的Culture播客网络的一部分。他们的全新球星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier Chicharito Hernandez）。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是个人。每一天，我都仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共处，从我出生起就是这样。
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
我依然有那么多的问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消资格？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything in here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has a perfect and all of us all. Wait me, I'm going to pressuram, but me will go to be able to be connect. The Chicharito.
从每天的平凡到深邃与非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱感在这里流露。阴谋论最终被摆上台面，目标和教训得以分享。这生活中的一切都是完美的，我们所有人也都是。等等我，我要压力山大，但我会能够去连接。小豌豆。
And together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary, stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Munges shit together and I'm back with a new season of the podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I'm diving into a rabbit hole of peptides, organoids, blood boys, blue zones and brain replacement to try to understand what this longevity obsession is all about and what it really means to live forever for all of us. I learned about some rad science.
与IHeart Radio一起，我们将把平凡变得非凡，敬请期待。这是一辆卡拉克。哇。在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》（learning to be human）。我是芒格什·希特·托杰（Munges shit together），我带着播客《天际线大道》（Skyline Drive）的新一季回来了。这一次，我正在深入探讨肽、类器官、换血疗法、长寿地区和大脑替代的兔子洞，试图理解这种长寿痴迷究竟是怎么回事，以及它对我们所有人来说，永远活着到底意味着什么。我了解了一些很酷的科学。
a brain for you and then we can test what draw is the best for your brain as opposed to his brain. Here's some hard truths. I would expect Indians to age faster, but I did not expect it to be almost a four to five year acceleration. And get myself into a world of trouble. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. Make it look more defined. They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If it wasn't clear already, I'm going to say it.
为你准备一个大脑，然后我们可以测试哪种药物最适合你的大脑，而不是他的大脑。以下是一些残酷的真相。我原以为印度人老得更快，但我没想到会加速整整四到五年。并且让自己陷入了大麻烦。我会说大概开始骨头重塑吧。那不管用。让它看起来更有轮廓感。他们说这管用。我不知道。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《天际线大道：如何永远活着》（Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever）。如果刚才还不够清楚的话，我要说出来了。
Analog is back in a huge way. When I say analog, what I mean is any activity that is by hand requires a little bit of friction or concentration and mainly requires your human input. We've kind of subtly spoken about this all day, but when we do analog things, parts of the activity, and not offloaded to a machine or technology. It's writing letters by hand. It's reading a physical book. It's baking from scratch. It's listening to vinyl records.
模拟时代以极大的规模卷土重来。当我所说“模拟”时，我的意思是任何通过手工进行的活动，都需要一点摩擦力或专注力，主要需要你的亲身投入。我们今天其实已经含蓄地讨论过这一点了，但当我们做模拟的事情时，活动的各个部分并没有被卸载给机器或技术。这是手写信件。这是阅读纸质书。这是从头开始烘焙。这是听黑胶唱片。
Like all of those are analog activities. A big one, though, that you should be doing more of if you want to repair your attentions ban is playing card games. I know, strange. But the evidence for the impact of card games on your cognitive ability is not spoken about enough. And that's exactly why I wanted.
就像所有这些都是模拟活动一样。不过，如果你想修复你的注意力持续时间，你应该多做的一项重大活动是玩纸牌游戏。我知道，这很奇怪。但纸牌游戏对你认知能力的影响，相关的证据还远远没有得到足够的讨论。而这正是我想
to include it. My favourite study on this was done by two University of Edinburgh researchers in 2019, who examined the relationship and association between playing card games or any analog game for that matter, so chess, checkers, and changes in cognitive function from 11 to 70. Now, this was a longitudinal study, and the participants were all born in Scotland in the 1930s and essentially assessed across their lifespan for, hey, are you playing card games? How's your memory? How's your memory? going, how's your attention going? And then they also controlled for factors like education, social class, activity, even early intelligence. And they showed that those of them who were engaging in card games, especially with friends, but even alone had greater cognitive speed and
把这一点包括进来的原因。我最喜欢的一项研究是由两位爱丁堡大学的研究人员于2019年进行的，他们研究了玩纸牌游戏或就此而言任何模拟游戏（比如国际象棋、西洋棋）与11岁到70岁认知功能变化之间的关系和关联。现在，这是一项纵向研究，参与者都是在20世纪30年代出生在苏格兰的，基本上在他们的整个生命历程中被评估，评估内容包括：嘿，你在玩纸牌游戏吗？你的记忆力怎么样？你的记忆力
greater attention. The same can be said for activities and hobbies that require a lot of hand-eye coordination or motor skills, like pottery, woodworking, rock climbing, dancing, and once more, sustained attention. There is cross-brain stimulation. Your brain is required as well to stick to the task for it to be good. That is expanding your cognitive endurance. If we think back to how our dopamine systems are being frayed and depleted by our current environment, analog activities provide a much-needed antidote because they are essentially doing the opposite. They require sustained problem-solving and attention. You don't get an immediate convenience reward from doing hard things. Your brain has to wait. Your brain has to be patient. And the payout
进展如何，你的注意力进展如何？然后他们还控制了诸如教育、社会阶层、活动甚至早期智力等因素。他们表明，那些参与纸牌游戏的人，特别是与朋友一起、甚至是独自一人的人，具有更高的认知速度和
feels more significant showing your brain, neurologically, psychologically, to do that again. And it feels better. You've worked on it for longer. The reward spurs more of that behavior. Taking from this as well, it's not just analog activities, but having analog afternoons, analog days, analog weekends, where you challenge yourself to do things without technology or digital input may prove to be an unconventional approach to retraining our attention spans, but once more, a highly effective one, the kind of guerrilla approach you might need right now. There's also just something so intimate about doing things
更高的注意力。对于需要大量手眼协调能力或运动技能的活动和爱好，比如陶艺、木工、攀岩、跳舞，以及再次强调的持续注意力，也是如此。这里存在跨脑刺激。为了保持良好状态，你的大脑同样被要求坚持完成任务。这正在扩展你的认知耐力。如果我们回想一下我们的多巴胺系统是如何被当前的环境磨损和消耗的，模拟活动提供了一剂急需的解药，因为它们基本上在做着相反的事情。它们需要持续的问题解决和注意力。你不会从做困难的事情中立即获得便利的奖励。你的大脑必须等待。你的大脑必须保持耐心。而回报
in a way that isn't necessarily convenient anymore, but feels really special and feels really sacred. You know, like your friend who films the birthday party on her camcorder, That is more special than a movie shot on an iPhone. Your friend who hand paints you a portrait rather than buying a gift off Amazon. That's better than the Amazon gift, you know, that portrait's better than an AI trend, taking two hours to really perfect a chocolate cake rather than Uberitzing a chocolate bar to your house. These things all feel more special.
感觉更重大，在神经学上、心理学上向你的大脑表明可以再次这样做。而且感觉更好。你在这上面付出了更长时间的努力。这种奖励会刺激更多这种行为。从中还可以吸取的一点是，不仅是模拟活动，还要有模拟下午、模拟日子、模拟周末，在这些时间里，你挑战自己不用技术或数字输入来做事，这可能被证明是重新训练我们注意力持续时间的一种非传统方法，但再次证明，这是一种高度有效的方法，可能是你现在所需要的游击式方法。用一种
Something I've learnt from doing this podcast is that so many modern psychological problems are really just solved by ancient primal solutions. Not all of them, but some of them. Obviously, the people of the past didn't do everything right. And advances in technology are like incredible. I'm not scoffing at them. I'm not saying, I'm not trying to push like a trad wife ideology. But just think about what environment your brain was made for. It wasn't the one that you are in now. Our brains are an ancient machine that adapted for thousands of years to go slow, to have to put an effort to get out. output to chase long-term gratification, they were literally trained on slow, sustained dopamine. That has changed incredibly rapidly.
不再一定那么方便、但感觉非常特别和神圣的方式来做事，其中也有一些非常亲密的东西。你知道的，就像你的朋友用摄像机拍摄生日派对，那比用iPhone拍摄的电影更特殊。你的朋友为你手绘一幅肖像，而不是从亚马逊上买一件礼物。那比亚马逊的礼物更好，你知道的，那幅肖像比人工智能趋势更好，花两个小时真正完善一块巧克力蛋糕，而不是通过Uber Eats点一块巧克力棒送到你家里。这些事情都感觉更加特殊。
Artificially turning that state back on for yourself by going analog at times when the world around you doesn't require you to is really helpful and really does change how you focus, change how you feel, change, yeah, once again, your attention span. Okay, tip number four or five, I don't know which one we're up to, let's say five. Separate your environments so that you can cue your brain to know when it's time to pay attention and when it's time to switch off. One of the reasons our attention spans, yours, mine, everybody's, feels so fragmented is because our brains no longer associate specific spaces with specific mental states. during the pandemic especially, our bedrooms became offices, our couches became classrooms, our phones with the cinema, everything was everything.
我从做这个播客中学到的一件事是，许多现代心理问题实际上只是通过古老的原始解决方案来解决的。并非全部，但其中一些是。显然，过去的人并没有把所有事情都做对。而且技术的进步是不可思议的。我并没有对它们冷嘲热讽。我不是说，我不是在试图推销一种传统的妻子意识形态。但只要想想你的大脑是为哪种环境而造的。它不是你现在身处的环境。我们的大脑是一台古老的机器，经过数千年的适应，变得节奏缓慢、需要付出努力才能产出、去追求长期满足感，它们实际上是在缓慢、持续的多巴胺刺激下受到训练的。这种改变发生得极其迅速。
Like it was, you know, your space, there was no clear delineation. And what this has stopped is what psychologists call context-dependent memory and behavior, where our brain learns to associate certain environments like your home or your bedroom with certain habits and emotions and other places like, your workplace or your desk with other habits and emotional states like alertness. So if you do everything everywhere, your brain never receives a clear signal about what specific mode it's meant to be in. This is why people who work from home often report feeling like they are never fully off, myself included, and it's why they also have a more strained
通过在周围世界并不要求你这样做的时候偶尔回归模拟，来为你自己人工重新开启这种状态，真的是很有帮助的，并且确实会改变你的专注方式、改变你的感受方式，再次改变你的注意力持续时间。好的，第四个还是第五个小贴士，我不知道我们讲到第几个了，就当是第五个吧。把你的环境分隔开，这样你就可以向大脑发出提示，知道什么时候该集中注意力，什么时候该放松。我们的注意力持续时间——你的、我的、所有人的——之所以感觉如此碎片化，原因之一在于我们的大脑不再将特定的空间与特定的心理状态联系起来。特别是在大流行期间，我们的卧室变成了办公室，我们的沙发变成了教室，我们的手机成了电影院，一切都是一切。
attentional system. There is no psychological boundary separating their states of being. and the requirements that those different states have. And without recovery, our focus deteriorates even more. Attention really actually requires contrast. Your brain needs spaces that say, here we can concentrate, and other spaces that say, here we can rest, here we can have fun, here we can be entertained. Otherwise, you kind of exist in the middle
就像是，你知道的，你的空间，没有明确的划分。而这所阻止的，是心理学家所说的情境依赖记忆和行为，即我们大脑学会将某些环境（如你的家或你的卧室）与某些习惯和情感联系起来，而将其他地方（如你的工作场所或你的书桌）与其他的习惯和情感状态（如警觉）联系起来。因此，如果你在所有地方做所有事情，你的大脑就永远不会收到关于它应该处于哪种特定模式的清晰信号。这就是为什么在家工作的人经常报告说他们感觉自己从未真正完全放松（包括我自己），这也是为什么他们有更紧张的
where you can't really do either. Like, you can't do one or the other, you do this secret third option, which is like both at the same time. So separate your spaces, bed for sleeping, only couch for phone, only office for work, only library for study only. Spaces have to have specific functions if you want to improve your attention span. What actually makes a good focus environment? Let's talk about that for a second. There's been a lot of research on this. An environment that's
注意力系统。没有任何心理界限将他们的存在状态以及这些不同状态所要求的条件隔离开来。而在没有恢复的情况下，我们的专注力会进一步退化。注意力其实真的需要对比。你的大脑需要这样的空间：在这里我们可以集中精力；而其他空间则说：在这里我们可以休息，在这里我们可以玩乐，在这里我们可以娱乐。否则，你就会有点存在于中间地带，
good for attention is firstly one that is low in visual clutter. So studies consistently show that clutter competes for our attention because every object in our visual field is processed by the brain to some extent. So even if you think you're ignoring the piles of clothes or random tabs or notifications, your brain is still allocating tiny bits of energy towards filtering them in or out or putting them on your to-do list. So having an environment where you pay attention and you focus, making sure that's one that is clear of clutter is super important. This is something this is someone called Dr. Emily Boucherist. She's a social psychologist at NYU. She talked about in a recent big think article, as much as attention is controlled cognitively and mentally,
在那里你实际上无法做到这两者中的任何一个。就像，你不能做这个或那个，你做了这个秘密的第三个选项，那就是两者同时进行。所以要分隔你的空间，床仅用于睡觉，沙发仅用于手机，办公室仅用于工作，图书馆仅用于学习。如果你想提高你的注意力持续时间，空间必须有特定的功能。究竟是什么造就了一个良好的专注环境？我们来谈谈这个。这方面有很多研究。一个对注意力有益的
it's also controlled visually. You have to think of your eyes as like flashlights. So whatever it's pointed at, it attends to. When you have multiple things in your environment, on your desk, on your wall, the flashlight is jumping between them when you have just one thing. So your laptop, your textbook, your computer, your notes, your flashlight finds it easier to settle on that singular object. This is actually called your visual focus muscle, by the way, and the more you can reduce the spotlight's diameter, the less preoccupied you are, which is better. So that's the first thing an environment often needs. Secondly, physical cues for concentration. This sounds simple, but having objects that only appear during focused work can become powerful mental triggers. Maybe it's a
环境首先是视觉杂乱度较低的环境。因此，研究一致表明，杂乱会争夺我们的注意力，因为我们视野中的每一个物体在某种程度上都会被大脑处理。所以，即使你认为自己忽视了一堆衣服、随机的标签或通知，你的大脑仍然在分配微小的能量来过滤它们进出，或者把它们列入你的待办事项清单。因此，拥有一个你可以集中注意力、专注的环境，确保这是一个没有杂乱的环境是超级重要的。这就是某个被称为艾米丽·布歇斯特（Dr. Emily Boucherist）博士的人所做的事。她是纽约大学的社会心理学家。她在最近的一篇“大思考”（Big Think）文章中谈到，注意力很大程度上是在认知和心理上受到控制的，
particular lamp you switch on, your noise-canceling headphones that you only use when you're working, specific playlist, candle, a certain chair, even a particular drink, for me, you guys know it's always a Diet Coke, that is my Get Stuff Done queue because it is the only caffeine I really have ever. And these things, the Diet Coke, the playlist, the headphones become what psychologists call conditioned stimuli, basically signals that prime the brain for certain states. athletes do this all the time before a competition. So to famous musicians. Lots of people do. It's part of the ritual of work. And finally, an environment that helps you pay attention and focus is one that has natural elements. So exposure to natural light, greenery, outdoor views,
它同时也是在视觉上受到控制的。你必须把你的眼睛想象成手电筒。所以无论它指向哪里，它就会关注哪里。当你的环境中有很多东西时，在你的桌子上、在你的墙上，当你只有一样东西时，手电筒就会在它们之间跳跃。所以你的笔记本电脑、你的课本、你的电脑、你的笔记，你的手电筒会发现更容易安定在那一个单一的物体上。顺便说一句，这实际上被称为你的视觉专注肌肉，而且你越能减小聚光灯的直径，你受到的干扰就越少，这会更好。所以这是环境通常需要的第一件事。其次，用于专注的物理线索。这听起来很简单，但拥有仅在专注工作时才出现的物品可以成为强大的精神触发器。也许它是
all have been shown to, or have been repeatedly linked, I should say, to improved attention restoration and reduced mental fatigue. Attention restoration theory in particular suggests that nature gives out directed attentional systems a chance to recover because natural environments engage the brain softly rather than harshly. Even a plan on your desk or working near a window can help. And now for my final tip, my final tip for getting your attention span back is to not overestimate the power of actually taking breaks. I think when we are on this quest to rebuild our attentional capacity, specifically the attentional capacity we once had, there's a real all or nothing thinking that can take over, especially when it's something we care about, we're really
你打开的某一盏特定的台灯，你只在工作时使用的降噪耳机，特定的播放列表、蜡烛、特定的椅子，甚至特定的饮料——对我来说，你们都知道这总是一杯健怡可乐——那是我的“开始干活”信号，因为这是我真正喝过的唯一咖啡因。这些东西——健怡可乐、播放列表、耳机——成为了心理学家所说的条件刺激，基本上是为大脑某些状态做好准备的信号。运动员在比赛前总是这样做。著名的音乐家也是如此。许多人都会这样做。这是工作仪式感的一部分。最后，一个能帮助你注意和专注的环境是包含自然元素的坏境。接触自然光、绿植、户外的风景，
worried about. You know, it's only natural to notice something's changed, like our attention, and to be fearful of what that means long term, and to try very drastically to force yourself into a state of focused, disciplined effort. You're not doing yourself any favors by demanding hours and hours of sustained attention for yourself thinking that that's helping, especially when it comes from a place of self-punishment or fear. In fact, psychology tells us that this approach often backfires. It's like somebody who wants to get fit and runs a marathon, suddenly overnight thinking that's helping with their muscle retention.
所有这些都被证明，或者说被反复证明——我应该这么说——与改善注意力恢复和减少精神疲劳有关。注意力恢复理论特别指出，大自然让我们的定向注意力系统有机会恢复，因为自然环境是以柔和而非严厉的方式吸引大脑。甚至你桌上的一株植物或在窗户附近工作也能有所帮助。现在是我的最后一个小贴士，我关于找回注意力持续时间的最后一个小贴士是，不要高估实际休息的力量。我认为，当我们处于重建注意力容量、特别是我们曾经拥有的那种注意力容量的探索中时，一种真正非黑即白的思维方式可能会占据主导地位，尤其是当这是我们关心的事情、我们真正
It's not we need to build up to it over time so that we can test our cognitive limits and then rest them and recover from that fatigue. When we force concentration beyond our cognitive limits, our brains, they don't become stronger, they just become fatigued and it can create learnt negative associations between our workspace, for example, the work we feel we need to do in exhaustion, boredom, frustration, meaning that we're not going to do it. There's also something called vigilance decrement. It's a phenomenon where our ability to sustain attention naturally declines over time when we
担心的事情时。注意到有些事情变了（比如我们的注意力），并对这意味着什么产生长期的恐惧，然后非常剧烈地试图迫使自己进入一种专注、纪律严明的努力状态，这是再自然不过的。要求自己进行长达数小时的持续注意力，并认为这有所帮助，你其实并没有帮到自己，尤其是当这种要求来自于自我惩罚或恐惧时。事实上，心理学告诉我们，这种方法往往会适得其反。这就像一个想要保持健康的人突然在一夜之间跑了一场马拉松，以为这有助于肌肉保持。
are continuously focused on one task for longer than necessary or than we want to be. This is why productivity researchers and neuroscientists alike really want people to take breaks. They are incredible for restoring your executive function, especially when a break involves movement, nature, silence, anything that allows your brain to momentarily disengage. And they're incredible for directing your attention because we know it's always so much easier to comfort.
根本不是这样，我们需要随着时间慢慢建立起来，这样我们才能测试我们的认知极限，然后让它们休息并从这种疲劳中恢复过来。当我们强迫集中注意力超过我们的认知极限时，我们的大脑不会变得更强，它们只会变得疲惫，并且这会在我们的工作空间（例如，我们在精疲力竭、无聊、沮丧中觉得必须要做的工作）之间产生学会的负面联想，这意味着我们不会去做了。还有一种叫做“警觉度下降”的现象。这是一种现象，即当我们
back to a task when we're not dreading it and when it feels novel. But if you sit down and are like, all right, let's go, we have to focus for 10 hours. Otherwise, I have a problem. All you're going to do is mean that the next time you have to concentrate or pay attention at all, you're going to feel the impending doom or the impending fear that like maybe I'm in for another 10 hour feet. I can't do this. I can't do this in the middle lane. I can either not pay attention, not be focused or be focused so much that I'm just as I'm just mentally and physically drained. And importantly, breaks are not laziness. They are part of this training that we're talking about.
连续专注于一项任务的时间超过必要或想要的时间时，我们维持注意力的能力会随着时间自然下降。这就是为什么生产力研究人员和神经科学家都真心希望人们去休息。它们对于恢复你的执行功能是不可思议的，特别是当休息涉及运动、大自然、沉默、任何能让你的大脑暂时脱离的事情时。它们对于引导你的注意力也是不可思议的，因为我们知道，当我们不畏惧一项任务并且它让人觉得新鲜时，重新回到这项任务总是要容易得多。但如果你坐下来然后说：“好吧，我们开始吧，我们必须集中注意力10个小时。否则，我就会有问题。”你所要做的就是意味着下一次你必须集中注意力时，你会感到一种即将降临的厄运或恐惧，觉得也许我要再经历一次10小时的折磨。我做不到。我无法处于中间状态。要么我无法集中注意力、无法专注，要么我就极度专注以至于我在精神上和体力上都筋疲力尽。重要的是，休息不是懒惰。它们是我们正在谈论的这种训练的一部分。
If you're trying to go from consuming 15 second videos all day to suddenly reading for uninterrupted hours, your brain is going to rebel, right? Instead, rebuild your attention span progressively. 20 focused minutes matters, 30 matters, an hour, matters. The goal is not perfection. It's consistency. Five minutes matter. You're trying to teach your brain that focus and attention is rewarding, is enjoyable, is safe. So, big episode, to summarize, your loss of attention or control is not you. It is the digital and physical environment you've been
如果你试图从一整天都在消费15秒的视频，突然变成连续数小时的不间断阅读，你的大脑会反抗，对吧？相反，要逐步重建你的注意力持续时间。20分钟的专注很重要，30分钟很重要，一个小时也很重要。目标不是完美。而是持续性。5分钟也很重要。你是在试图教导你的大脑，专注和注意力是有回报的、是有趣的、是安全的。所以，这是一个内容丰富的节目，总结一下，你注意力或控制力的丧失并不是你的问题。而是你一直身处其中的数字和物理环境导致的
forced into. You are definitely not the only one experiencing that decline, but it is something that you can reverse due to the beauty and I guess the gift of neuroplasticity. So if you want to rebuild your attention span, number one, get clear on what is motivating you to change and the benefits of this change. Two, set a baseline to measure your progress against. Three, you don't have to stop using your phone, but stop using multiple screens specifically at once. Four, create friction so that using your phone or social media isn't as easy. Five, give yourself a daily attention broadening exercise, 30 minutes every day where you just focus on doing one thing at once.
被迫陷入。你绝对不是唯一经历这种能力退化的人，但这完全是可以逆转的，因为神经可塑性具有奇妙的力量。所以如果你想重建注意力跨度，第一，明确是什么在激励你做出改变以及这种改变的好处。第二，设定一个基准来衡量你的进展。第三，你不需要停止使用手机，但要停止同时使用多个屏幕。第四，制造一些阻力，让使用手机或社交媒体没那么容易。第五，每天给自己做一个拓宽注意力的练习，每天花30分钟专注于一次只做一件事。
Six, stop listening to music or always having background noise on when you complete simple tasks. Just give your brain some silence to replenish itself, especially when you're doing things that require attention. Seven, return to analog activities, particularly those that require. friction and concentration. They are going to save your attention more than anything else. Eight, design your environment to be more conducive to your attentional goals, limited clutter, one thing at a time, nature in your environment. Those are the three things. I don't know what number we're up to, but take breaks and measure back against your baseline as you progress.
第六，完成简单任务时，不要听音乐或一直开着背景噪音。给你的大脑一些安静的时间来恢复精力，特别是当你做需要注意力的事情时。第七，回归模拟活动，尤其是那些需要阻力和专注力的活动。它们比任何事情都更能拯救你的注意力。第八，设计你的环境，使其更有利于实现你的注意力目标：减少杂物，一次只做一件事，环境中引入自然元素。这是三点。我不知道我们数到第几点，但随着进展，记得休息并对照基准进行衡量。
The thing is, you absolutely have the power to do this. Like, you absolutely do. And if you're thinking about it, you also should absolutely do it now. I fully believe, as I've said in this episode, as AI becomes more dominant as well, and makes things even easier and easier and more convenient, the people who are going to continue to thrive and be successful are those who still know the power of effort and can execute effort through sustained attention and focus. What's more, I think there's just genuine human beauty in doing things the hard way, even if they're not not perfect, even if they're not the best, even if it requires more from you cognitively mentally. There's beauty in that. So I hope this episode gets you closer back to that state
关键是，你完全有能力做到这一点。真的绝对可以。如果你正在考虑这件事，你也绝对应该现在就开始。我完全坚信，正如我在本集节目中所说的那样，随着人工智能变得越来越为主流，让事情变得越来越简单、越来越方便，那些能够继续蓬勃发展并取得成功的人，依然是那些懂得付出努力的力量，并能通过持续的注意力和专注力来执行努力的人。更重要的是，我认为以困难的方式做事本身就有一种纯粹的人性之美，即使它们并不完美，即使它们不是最好的，即使这在认知和精神上对你有更多的要求。这里面有一种美。所以我希望这一集能让你重新回到那种状态
of being that you can remember being in as a kid or as a teenager. I think a lot of us are really realizing the cost of the online life and the overstimulated life on our brain. So you're not the only one. I think these tips will hopefully get you to the start line, past the start line, hopefully get you rebuilding your attentional muscle because it is possible if you can think of anything else that's helped you and you want to share it with the audience and you're listening on Spotify. You can leave comment below. I would honestly love to hear from you. I feel like this is a massive talking point at the moment. Any delusional tips or things or strategies that have worked for you, feel free to share them below.
一种你还记得自己小时候或青少年时期的状态。我想我们很多人都真正意识到了网络生活和过度刺激的生活对我们大脑造成的代价。所以你不是一个人。我希望这些提示能让你站在起跑线上，甚至跨过起跑线，帮你重新建立起注意力肌肉，因为这确实是可能的。如果你能想到其他对你有帮助并想与听众分享的事情，而且你正在用Spotify收听，你可以在下方留言。老实说，我很想听到你的想法。我觉得这是目前一个巨大的热门话题。任何对你有用的疯狂小贴士、事情或策略，请随时在下方分享。
Some other reminders, you can also watch this episode on Netflix. If you want to see what the studio looks like, if you want a more, I don't know, personal way of enjoying the podcast. You can follow us on Instagram. You can read our substack where we send a version of the podcast in written form to you once a week. And you know what? If you made it this far and you didn't speed up the episode and you didn't get bored halfway through, maybe you did. know, maybe it was just a boring episode, but if you paid attention all the way to the end of this episode, congratulations. You did two of your sustained attention exercises for the day.
其他一些提醒：你也可以在Netflix上观看这一集。如果你想看看录音室长什么样，如果你想要一种我不知道的、更个人化的方式来享受这个播客。你可以在Instagram上关注我们。你可以阅读我们的Substack，我们每周会把播客的文字版发送给你一次。你知道吗？如果你坚持到了这里，没有把这一集加速播放，也没有在半途感到无聊（也许你真的觉得无聊，也许这只是一集无聊的节目），但如果你一直聚精会神地听到了这一集的最后，恭喜你。你今天完成了两项持续注意力练习。
You are incredible. I'm wishing you all very good luck on your attentional capacity journeys. It's a weird sentence. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotbi. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and Listen Now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS.
你们太不可思议了。祝你们在注意力容量的旅程中一切顺利。这真是一句奇怪的话。但下次见之前，请保持安全，保持善良，对自己温和一点。我们很快就会聊。快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。但现在，有一种全新且令人兴奋的方式来开启你走向更快乐生活旅程的方法。快乐101。这是一个全新的播客，由我（霍达·科特比）主持。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋且感人的现场聊天。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“快乐101”并立即收听。由CVS呈献的霍达·科特比主持的《快乐101》。
My first guest is Terence Hilton, Shakita, Luke and Yerrin. Have surprises? Many surprises. Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast where the group check comes to life. What on? You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305.
我的第一位嘉宾是特伦斯·希尔顿、沙基塔、卢克和耶林。有惊喜吗？有很多惊喜。欢迎来到Sweet 305播客，这里是集体八卦照进现实的地方。什么？你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。这里是Sweet 305。
Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems. mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive.
在这里，过度分享受到鼓励。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听勒勒·庞斯的《Sweet 305》。每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我都在学习如何带着问题、错误、人际关系和情绪生活，自从我出生以来就是这样。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活著意味着什么的诚实对话。
I'm Javier Tchariot-Randes and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. I'm Mangishatigula and I'm back with a new season of my podcast, Skyline Drive. This time I talked to scientists, biopunks, kermudgeon, blues owners, super seniors, and Goa's top cryotherapy lab. to try to understand this obsession with living forever and what it means for all of us. And I get into a bit of trouble along the way. I'd say probably start bone smashing. That doesn't work. To make it look more defined.
我是哈维尔·查里奥-兰德斯，请在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。我是芒吉沙·蒂古拉，我带着我的播客《天际线大道》的新一季回来了。这一次，我与科学家、生物朋克、脾气暴躁的老头、蓝调音乐人、超级老年人和果阿的顶级冷冻疗法实验室交谈，试图理解这种对长生不老的痴迷以及这对我们所有人的意义。在这一过程中我也遇到了一些麻烦。我会说，可能从砸骨头开始。那不管用。为了让它看起来更立体。
They say it works. I don't know. Listen to Skyline Drive, How to Live Forever on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is Michael Rappaport, and my podcast, the I Am Rappaport's stereo podcast is unlike anyone you've ever heard. If you're looking for strong opinions about sports, entertainment, politics, pop culture, and whatever else catches my attention, then subscribe now. This kid Jafar Jackson should absolutely positively get nominated for his portrayal as Michael Jackson.
他们说这管用。我不知道。在iHeart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《天际线大道：如何长生不老》。我是迈克尔·拉帕波特，我的播客《我是拉帕波特立体声播客》与你听过的任何人都不一样。如果你在寻找关于体育、娱乐、政治、流行文化以及任何引起我注意的事情的强烈观点，那就赶紧订阅吧。这个叫杰法尔·杰克逊的小伙子绝对应该因其对迈克尔·杰克逊的塑造而被提名。
Listen to I Am Rap Report on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《I Am Rap Report》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。